Matt R special came
out and your brother sent me a text
today and he was like uh hey what do you
think about this Matt R controversy I'm
like with too many abs what's what's did
he grow a ninth and tth ab like we don't
we' ever seen that he was like no he
said he's getting killed for his first
joke and his special and then which was
I guess was a domestic violence joke Y
and then for the people that were
complaining he sent a link said this is
if you're complaining here's where you
should leave your complaints mhm and it
was a link for people to buy a special
needs helmet yes okay let me say a
couple things first of all dude his
response was [__] perfect and
hilarious and hilarious and you know
what he wants those people who are
touchy he wants them out of his fan base
good for him dude he's drawing a line
right [__] now you want to laugh it's
silly you want me to you want and
domestic violence isn't silly but let me
just say this about yo dude first of all
if you don't like a joke just don't
watch that comedian yeah that that's it
don't get up because I guarantee you
everybody who laughs or who does who
thinks that joke isn't funny is laughing
at another joke that other people think
is offensive right do you know what I'm
saying so you're picking and choosing by
your own morality and ethics what but I
can laugh at this for I'm going to give
an example like not comparing the two
that like domestic violence and
Christianity or Trump right right like
it's okay to make fun of this vast
religion and everybody who right right
which a lot of people do tons yeah yeah
yeah yeah right you're picking and
choosing listen either you laugh at
everything or you laugh at nothing
you're not allowed to [__] pick and
choose just cuz something bothers
you right that is not okay because I I
promise you and I'll just like I promise
you that maybe a black guy wouldn't
laugh at a black joke but he'd laugh at
a fat joke not okay I dude I'm laughing
at je jokes I'm laughing at je jokes I I
and by the way there's a lot of them
going around right now I'm laughing at
je jokes okay I'm laughing at all of
them if it's funny it's funny that's all
it is but let me just say this about his
domestic violence joke up front yo man
it's not even like and even if he hears
this it's not even like the most and I
don't I don't mean this as a knock
because as comics when you're dealing
with big broad issues we're going to
hone in on some of the same stuff that
doesn't mean like like like a million
people have done jokes about teachers
having sex with students right right
it's just something funny that that
doesn't mean one person person is
stealing from the other it's just such a
big broad topic and everybody kind of
finds the same area because that same
area I I bet you there's a thousand
Comics who have said something like um
because the mom always is the person who
turns the the teacher in it's never the
dad right because the dad's like dude
that's [__] yeah was pretty awesome
yeah right absolutely so that's the joke
and everybody's done some sort of like
variation of that his domestic Dr
violence joke was
basically there was a woman out to eat
um she had a black guy I'm gonna
paraphrase but that like
um his basic joke was if if she could
they broke it down something said like
maybe she should have been in the
kitchen cooking it was they were out at
a restaurant right right and he was like
I think that if she could cook maybe she
wouldn't have the black eye yeah
right
it everybody has made some who's touched
this topic has been in that silly
ridiculous big broad
area you can tell by who he is by the
way he delivers jokes by the way he does
his crowd work he goes in but in the
most nonserious way right it's like
watching Shane Gillis and thinking he
like he means all of Y dude he's this is
where he he finds dark funny that's fine
yeah but you have to guys Comics these
Comics are trying to make you laugh look
at their intent the intent is to make
you laugh I promise you Matt R is a very
respectful young man he's not out
beating people he's not pro- domestic
violence and that joke is not making
anybody go home and hit their wife yeah
you know what you touchy [__] you
touchy
[__] you look
man just because it's not fun for you
doesn't mean other people aren't having
fun with it you don't get to be the
[__] fun police and you don't get to
police what other people think is funny
and some of us like dark humor I like
all the dark humor man me too I like all
of it yo I will laugh at a straight up
racist joke if it's funny I laugh man I
am the furthest thing from racist I will
laugh at a domestic violence joke is it
funny I will laugh at a seist joke is it
funny I'll laugh at a Jew joke is it
funny that's all it is to me is it funny
and is the intent of the person telling
it to make me laugh yeah that's it
because people don't understand that
line between it like a the intent like
that's what exactly what you're saying
is some people are saying it as a joke
but also thinking the intent behind the
joke is is to be malicious when that is
most of the time not the intention there
are some Comics who don't know that line
to where the jokes sound more Ru like
rude and cruel than it is funny it's
it's all about the intention and tone
and how somebody says it there's a guy
named Kevin Brennan uh Neil Brennan's
brother and Neil and Kevin are not close
and Kevin is the
dude who
is he he his jokes do cross right he is
a he's a mean comic right right and he's
been pretty much ostracized out of the
community because of it yeah we're not
into that [__] either we're into funny
yeah because that also that type of
comic makes all everybody every other
comic look that 100% guys
yo there are so many other important
things in the world than you trying to
play gotcha cop with
comedians there are so many other
[__] things and if you don't think
something's funny which is cool yo dude
there's a lot of comics who are very
successful that I don't think are funny
that's fine that doesn't mean they're
bad that means that's not the type of
art that I like so this is not the type
of art you like and people getting on
him about his
comedy because I've read you told me
that some people are like it's not
getting reviewed that well yeah yeah
guys he is such a young comic yeah a
[__]
infant as a comic his crowd work is next
level it is so far beyond his years
because he is an improv dude and his
crowd work is so far I am so impressed
with his crowd work it is so
conversational and so quick and dark and
his audience allows him to be dark
because he knows they know what the deal
is his comedy will catch up it will it's
the same [__] when I hear people giving
Brendan job hard time oh man these these
guys get exposure really quick and it's
hard to say no to a special it's hard to
say no to the
attention but with all the attention
people are expecting you to be Dave
Chappelle there's only one Dave
Chappelle and that's Dave Chappelle yeah
absolutely right
so I I I yo do you know
me I love stand-up comedy I love standup
comics I it has it continues to grow my
love for standup comedy and my love for
comedians it continues to grow it's
gotten better I have as I get older I
have more appreciation for what goes
into this job and to be
successful at it and so I I have so much
respect for Matt and how hard he's
[__] worked and uh and I I hope this
doesn't well it definitely doesn't
bother him just judging by his response
y his respon response was perfect his
response was hey [__] you ride with me
or put the helmet on I don't care which
is exactly what it should be he should
not be catering his art to a certain few
people anybody yeah the deal with art yo
whoever your favorite artist
is I promise you they do their art
because they like it and they hope
somebody Art's all about perspective
dude it is all about if I'm making my
art because I think you like it it's
going to be shitty